Fon and fancy-free only one thing could
be gayer than that title and there he is
yes I said before I'm not a huge fan of
Jiminy Cricket but luckily he doesn't
have that much to do with this just like
the other films there's no one story but
in this there's not really a bunch of
them either there's only two and Jiminy
Cricket
for whatever reason hosts them it's
strange that they would actually call
this movie fun and fancy-free instead
just the two titles it's not like make
mine music where if you listed all the
titles it wouldn't be enough room here
there's only two Bongo and Jack and the
Beanstalk heck that's a shorter title
than Ichabod and mr. toad they could
have done it but heck with that how did
the stories hold up well as the other
Disney stories go even for the short
ones it's nothing that special they're
okay though the first ones called Bongo
it's about a bear who used to work in
the circus but escapes to live in the
wild he finds he doesn't quite fit in
but things change when he comes across a
female bear but then he gets confused
when she starts beating the out of
him but then the movie so colorfully
tells us that the way bears show that
they love each other is beating the
out of each other makes sense to me yeah
even as a kid I thought that was a
little weird and I'm still not sure I
buy it now but it makes for a cute song
everybody like
to say beside and that's the best way to
describe the first short cute I really
liked it as a kid but looking back it
does go on a little too long if they
were gonna do this and make it work they
should either make it its own movie with
much more characters or make it a lot
shorter then there's a really weird
transition where Jiminy Cricket is
somehow invited to a party a party where
puppets come to life and strange creepy
men do weird sounds with their hands and
the parents are nowhere to be seen
yeah this would not fly today you know
Ophelia you look so sweet but I say I
think you look so sweet yeah but that
segues into Jack and the Beanstalk the
first appearance of Mickey Mouse in any
movie since Fantasia
believe it or not the last time you
overhear Walt Disney do his voice we
also get Goofy and Donald into the mix
as it's pretty much just the
straightforward story of Jack and the
Beanstalk not really any major
differences I say the only thing that
really stands out about it is the giant
who is sort of this enjoyable doofus and
they added this really weird plot device
where he could change into anything
isn't that strange
he's already a giant why do you have to
give him more magical stuff being a
giant's enough on top of it they don't
really do anything with it there's a
whole Shea scene at the end where he's
trying to get them but when it just make
more sense if you turn to a cheetah or
something the film doesn't quite have
the flow or creativity that make my
music head and to be honest I don't know
what the connection is with all these
things you have Jiminy Cricket than a
bear from a circus into the wild then a
creepy man with puppets and then Jack
and the Beanstalk how's it all tied
together individually we work okay
as cartoons but I don't think there's
enough of them to really warrant a film
or if they did pick two they'd have to
do ones that are particularly unique or
particularly cinematic and the Earthies
really aren't again they're not bad
they're just not anything that special
but they have their own charm and
likeability to them so I guess they work
out I'd say it's probably better just to
rent them individually and skip the
middle parts but that's just me you know
looks good to you you'll probably like
it
you